So welcome everyone.
Our speaker today,
this is the first time she has
missed a very special engagement. Uh,
and that is the Vancouver Ukulele circle.
So Stephanie Gray is actually
an avid Ukulele player,
but in addition to that,
uh,
she is a Canadian who has spent more
than 15 years giving over 800 talks and
debates as well as hundreds
of media interviews on
abortion to diverse audiences
in the United States, Canada,
Australia, Latvia, England, Ireland,
Costa Rica,
and Guatemala in university settings.
She has debated Dr Fraser fellows,
a late term abortionist,
Ron Fitzsimmons,
then executive director of the national
coalition of abortion providers,
Elizabeth Kevin Dash a then legal
director for Naral pro choice America and
doctor Malcolm pots,
the first medical director
for the International Planned
Parenthood Federation.
Uh, she's the author of
love unleashes life, uh,
abortion and the art
of communicating truth.
And we have copies of her book available,
uh,
for a subsidized price of $5. So
if you're interested, come and, uh,
buy a copy after the talk.
So with no further delay,
I will introduce Ms. Stephanie Gray.
Thank you. It's wonderful to be
here. I love asking questions.
In fact, I have a friend who has
nicknamed me inquisitive Stephanie,
and in my vast travels around the world,
I have asked a lot of people
the following question,
who inspires you?
And whenever someone answers that question
for me, I then follow it up with why.
And here's what I've discovered.
Very often there are different answers
for who inspires the individuals I've
encountered,
but I've begun to notice a trend,
a theme when it comes to why certain
individuals inspire us and as I have asked
people for the reasons for why
certain people inspire them,
what I've discovered is it seems generally
the people who are inspiring have
suffered in some way or they face
some sort of obstacle or some sort of
challenge or some sort of difficulty.
And what sets them apart from those who
don't inspire is how they respond to
their suffering.
To the challenge to the difficulty and
what I've noticed this trend is that it
seems inspiring.
People in the face of
obstacles and suffering and
difficulty have at least three
qualities in common.
They put others ahead of themselves,
they have perspective and
they do the right thing.
Even when it's hard, you do the
right thing even when it's hard.
And so what I wanted to do today was
look at each of those qualities in more
detail and relate them to the very
controversial topic of abortion and a
particular,
I want to share with you
various conversations and
encounters I have had with
people of all different backgrounds and
viewpoints when it comes to abortion and
how I have been able to use those three
qualities and show how they align very
much with the perspective that I hold,
which is the prolife perspective.
When it comes to that first quality that
of putting others ahead of ourselves,
I would suggest that regardless
of someone's political persuasion,
love is universally attractive.
It is universally magnetic,
and ultimately that's what putting
others ahead of ourself is.
That's what love is. It's
willing. The others good.
And I would suggest that again,
regardless of our political persuasion,
each individual has a battle internally
between times where they put others
ahead of themselves and times where they
don't put others ahead of themselves.
I was once debating with a college
student in Florida a few years ago and we
were debating on the topic of abortion
and in our conversation, I'll admit,
I was thinking to myself,
he sounds selfish now.
Perhaps I could identify that so readily
because I knew that there were many
times I have been selfish.
In fact,
I can think of a time recently
on one of my frequent flights,
I had settled into my seat and there
was one empty seat next to me and sure
enough that passenger came along to
sit down and as she was coming down the
aisle,
she was talking with someone else and it
was very clear that they were traveling
together and it was very clear that the
person she was with was further at the
back of the plane and this thought
entered my head, I should offer my seat.
That would be nice.
I'm traveling alone.
I can take her friends seats so
they can sit next to each other.
But then I thought to myself,
I don't like sitting near the back of the
plane and I don't feel like getting up.
And so I didn't offer my seat and I have
to admit later that day I was kind of
reflecting on my day and I regretted
that decision of inaction and I thought
that was selfish.
And my overarching thought was if I move,
how will this impact me?
That's self interested
instead of if I move,
how will this impact them?
That's other oriented.
So I recognize that weakness within
me and that that wasn't attractive.
The attractive quality is the one that
is other oriented. So I bring that up,
taking us now back to my encounter
with his college student talking about
abortion, where he sounded selfish
and I was thinking to myself,
even though I have made selfish choices,
even though he sounds selfish,
I believe deep down we're
all drawn to selflessness.
How can I draw this out of him?
And besides loving questions,
I also love stories and as it should
happen as I was with a student,
a story came to my mind that
I had read about in the news.
The year was 2012 that this student
and I were talking and around that time
there had been that Costa Concordia
cruise ship accident where the cruise ship
had been steered a little too close to
shore on you're an Italian village and uh,
hit ground and sank and
people lost their lives.
And so I said to this student
that I was dialoguing with,
do you remember hearing about that on
the news? You said yes. And I said,
that made international attention.
And I said it drew
international attention,
not just because it was a major
passenger vehicle that had an accident,
not just because people died,
but there was another element to this
story that shocked people around the
world.
Who remembers what it was.
Anyway,
the captain left the ship and
that's what the students said to me.
He answered my question about
this story by saying, well,
the captain abandoned ship.
Now,
apparently the captain says the the ship
fell over and he fell into a a boat.
But the point was,
the news had been reporting it this way.
And so the student remembered that.
So then I said to him,
and how did our world respond? Did
our world respond by saying, Hey,
that was a really brilliant
choice of that captain,
or did our world respond by
saying, how could he have
done that? And he said, well,
it was the ladder. Our world was saddened
by that kind of reaction. Studies it,
let's contrast that captain
with another captain.
None of a cruise ship but of an airplane.
And I said to this student a few years
ago, now, this was many years ago now,
but back in 2012 a few
years prior to that,
in 2009 there had been a US airways plane
that had taken off from Laguardia when
my country of Canada got in the way.
We have these really annoying Canadian
geese and I don't know if they make their
way down here, but they certainly
made their way to New York.
And so there was a whole flock of
Canadian geese that were flying around the
exact same flight pattern
as this us airways flight.
And so I said to the student,
you know is this plane was taking off
and these Canadian geese were flying
nearby.
They got sucked into the engines of the
airplane and it caused immediate engine
failure. Do you remember that? I said to
the student, he said, yes, I do. I said,
the captain of that airplane Chesley
Sullenberger realized that he needed to
make an emergency landing because
if he didn't control the landing,
the plane was going to crash
with a dual engine failure.
And he realized he could
not get back to LaGuardia.
You couldn't get to Teterboro or any
of the other surrounding airports.
And so we thought,
I'm going to try to do a water landing.
And he managed to safely land that US
airways plane on the Hudson River in what
became known as the miracle on the Hudson.
And I said to the student,
when that plane came to a stop and
everyone inside would have gone to the
nearest exit to get off,
that meant the people at the back of the
plane would have gone to the back exit.
But one of the first people to get to the
back door didn't realize that the tail
of the airplane was tucked in the water.
So when they whipped that door open,
the Hudson River starts flooding into
this airplane. So I said to the student,
now everyone is getting away from the
back of the plane and they're escaping out
the middle doors and the front doors
and they're getting off except for one
person,
Captain Chesley Sullenberger as everyone's
getting off and away from the back,
he's staying on and walking towards
the back and his water was filling the
cabinet about waist level. He
walked the aisle, not just once,
but twice to make sure no one was left
on the plane and he was the last person
to get off.
What did our world say about him?
I asked this student and he
said, a hero. Correct? I said,
why? And he said, well, because
he had dependent passengers
and he cared for them.
He prioritize their needs.
He put them ahead of himself and I said,
do you think that's an example
we should follow? He said, yes,
and so I knew by his reaction to that
story that he shared the view I have that
even if we sometimes fail
and being other oriented,
we know that that's how we ought to
be and that's the example to follow.
And so once we can establish that,
I then brought it back to the topic of
abortion that we were debating and I
said,
if you agree that it was correct for the,
the the pilot to put the passengers ahead
of himself to prioritize the needs of
his dependence,
then wouldn't it follow that when it
comes to the topic of abortion and an
unplanned pregnancy that a pregnant woman
ought to prioritize the needs of her
dependent her preborn child,
much like a passenger on the airplane
who's in a vulnerable position and need
someone who's more skilled and older
and capable of helping them to help them
out. Now, some people respond by saying,
well wait, there's a big difference there.
You're comparing apples to oranges,
the people getting off of the airplane,
those passengers, we're human
beings, embryos and fetuses aren't,
so you can't make that comparison.
And I would suggest that that comparison
is valid or invalid depending on indeed
whether embryos and fetuses
are human beings like the
passengers on the airplane.
And so in my work I often wrestle with
that question in conversations with
people trying to discern
when does life begin?
And a good question because
remembering I love questions.
A good question that I'll
often ask people is this,
do you believe in human rights?
And I can tell you I have asked that
question around the world and consistently
I get one answer. Yes. And if
someone believes in human rights,
I then like to say,
okay,
well what about this human's rights
in the case of this seven week embryo?
Now sometimes people will look at an image
like that and say that's not a human.
And if that's someone's
reaction than in conversation,
I think rather than
preaching at an individual,
a good strategy to take
is to just ask a question.
And the question I like to ask is,
what are her parents?
Is the pregnant woman human?
Is Her partner human?
If yes,
wouldn't it logically follow that their
offspring must be of the same species?
So then someone might object and say,
well,
even if biologically that's human,
it's not alive.
Well,
I found myself in a conversation with
another college student a few years ago
and I asked him what he thought about
abortion. He said, I'm pro choice. I said,
why are you pro choice? And he said,
well, because the fetus isn't alive.
And so I just asked another question.
If the fetus isn't alive,
why do you need to do an abortion?
And he stopped and he
looked at me and he said,
I'm going to talk to you.
I never thought of it that way.
And so we spent about 30 minutes engaging
in a friendly civil dialogue as a
result of a question. If someone objects
to the idea that the embryo was alive.
I think another good
question to ask is this,
is the embryo growing at moment of
fertilization when you have a one celled
embryo,
is that one cell growing into two and
are those two growing into four and eight
and 16 and so forth.
And if yes,
when it followed by virtue
of the embryos growth,
the embryo must be living and
if the embryo has human parents,
wouldn't it follow by virtue of
that that the embryo must be human.
And if we believe in human rights,
then wouldn't it follow what we know
to be a living human has the same human
rights as you or me. Now someone
might objected that point and say,
but it's just a fetus
or it's just an embryo.
And so I think a good question to ask
that I've asked many people is this,
what kind of fetus I think about
that term for moment fetus,
that's not species specific. So
other species have fetuses, a dogs,
if he does his dolphins of
fetuses and humans have fetuses.
So the word fetus doesn't so much tell
us what something is but tells us how old
something is. So again, with my love
of questions, I'll often ask people,
when a fetus is born to human parents
and is in the arms of the mother,
what do we now call the fetus at that
moment? And people will say, well, a baby.
And, and then when the baby turns two,
what do we call the baby? I'll ask.
And toddler is what people say.
And then when the toddler turns 13,
what do we call the toddler? I was once
giving a talk and elderly woman piped up.
Impossible.
That's what we call that individual.
And then when possible turns 21, what do
we call impossible. Even more impossible,
right?
So the point is that we humans have
words to refer to age ranges within our
species. And so the words
adult or teenager, toddler,
baby,
fetus and embryo,
simply tell us how old an
entity is not what an entity is.
If we want to know what that entity is,
we have to ask what are the parents.
Now when it comes to the abortion debate,
one, one thing that I have found, um,
that provokes a lot of conversation is
defining the exact moment the fetus or
the embryo came to be.
And a lot of times we as a culture
will resist the idea that when debating
abortion,
that life would begin at fertilization.
And so what I'd like to suggest is that
if we weren't talking about abortion,
we as a society would more readily
accept that life begins at fertilization.
In fact, we already do. And a good
question to consider involves this, this,
this, uh, the following. Uh,
imagine someone is not pregnant
with an unwanted pregnancy.
Imagine they're trying
to achieve a pregnancy,
they desperately want to be pregnant,
but they're struggling with infertility.
So imagine this person goes to an
infertility specialist and that physician
recommends in vitro fertilization or
IVF where sperm will be an egg will be
fertilized by a sperm in
a petri dish in a lab.
Now setting aside the ethics of that,
which could be a whole other group talk
at Google, a setting aside the ethics,
ethics of that.
Imagine the individual then
goes to an IVF specialist.
Have we as a society ever heard someone
who's in the business of making life,
someone who's an IVF specialist
and we ever heard them say,
I just don't know when life begins.
If you think about it,
when someone is in the
business of making life,
we never claimed to not know when it
begins. We know exactly when it begets.
The one moment that the IVF specialist
is trying to replicate in the lab is the
moment of fertilization.
The IVF specialist is not
happy with just a sperm sample.
They're not happy with eggs
harvested by, uh, perhaps, uh,
a student in debt trying to get 10
or $20,000 for such a procedure.
They're not satisfied with just
the eggs are just the sperm.
The one moment they're trying to
create in the lab is not, you know, uh,
three weeks where you have a heartbeat
or six weeks where you have brainwaves or
a nine months just aided fetus.
The one moment the IVF specialist is
trying to create in the lab is the moment
of fertilization, which I think
tells us we do know when life begins.
We know it begins there particularly when
we think about other species a little
less controversial than our own.
We never hear horse breeders say,
I just don't know how to breed a horse.
I don't know when a horse becomes a horse
or you know someone who's, you know,
breeding dogs or have a
veterinarian and general saying,
I don't know when a dog becomes a dog
with other species. We have great clarity.
So why with our own species
when it comes to abortion,
do we claim to not know when life begins
or we claim that that it's confusing
when with these other species
or this other topic like IVF,
we have great clarity and we know
that moment to be fertilization.
When it comes to the
debate about abortion,
what I have found in debating people
formally and informally all over the world
is that it's less of a scientific
debate and more of a philosophical one.
Less a question of when does life begin?
Because really we know the
answer to that fertilization.
But more question about personhood,
which is not really a scientific
discussion but a philosophical one.
And there's a whole school
of thought by a philosopher,
Peter Singer from Princeton
University who argues abortion, um,
is justified and he even argue some
infanticide would be justified.
His School of thought comes from the
perspective of a definition of personhood
that would exclude preborn and some born
children and he would say a person is
someone who is rational, conscious
and self aware. And so I,
I have encountered people and
perhaps some of the room today, some,
some listening in who would argue that
even if biologically the embryo and the
fetus are human,
that philosophically they're not persons.
And that's why we could justify abortion.
That's why we wouldn't have to protect
embryos and fetuses the way it was.
Good for Captain Sullenberger to protect
the passengers on the airplane because
there are people but
embryos and fetuses aren't.
So then the question we have to wrestle
with is what is the right definition of
a person? Is a person, someone who's
rational, conscious and self aware.
So that if you're not those things,
you're not a person.
Well, what I like to do is
ask the question, why isn't,
let's say a one celled human
embryo at fertilization.
Why isn't that embryo rational,
conscious herself aware.
I think we know the answer to that is,
well the embryo is lacking the
Oregon necessary to be rational,
conscious and self aware and
that's the brain. So then we,
if we step back from and say,
well why?
Why doesn't the embryo at
fertilization have a brain?
We know the answer that will,
the embryo is the embryo
hasn't had time to develop.
The brain in time is reflected in our age.
So the one celled human embryo,
yes,
isn't rational conscious herself aware
in that moment but ultimately isn't able
to do those things or be that
way because of how old she is.
Now let's contrast that with let's say
an Amoeba. The AMOEBA is not rational.
Conscious herself aware. Why? Well
because the Amoeba doesn't have a brain.
Well why doesn't the Amoeba have a brain?
Not because it hasn't developed it yet,
but because it's not within
its nature to develop a brain.
Because it's not within its nature to
be a thinking thing. So in other words,
and Amoeba is not rational conscious or
self aware because of what it is versus
a human embryo who is not rational,
conscious or self aware
because of how old she is.
So then that brings me back to
the question about human rights.
Who gets human rights isn't the
necessary criteria simply being human.
If we were talking for
example about women's rights,
the necessary criteria for getting
the right would be being a woman.
If we were to talk
about children's rights,
the necessary criteria
would be being a child.
So when we talk about human rights, the
necessary criteria simply is being human,
not being human in a certain age.
And so the question is,
should personhood be grounded in how old
we are or should personhood be grounded
in what we are? Well,
to answer that question,
I find it helpful to go
to the United Nations.
The United Nations has a number of
different documents on human rights.
And as I have read these,
I've been astounded by several
things that have stood out to me.
The first is that in the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights,
that a is a document
by the United Nations.
It very clearly says all members of the
human family have the right to life.
So in other words,
to get the right to life,
all that matters is that you're
a member of the human family.
But that document does reference
persons and it referenced persons,
references persons.
In article six in an article six of the
Universal Declaration of Human Rights,
it says everyone has a right
to recognition everywhere
as a person before the
law. Well, let's define
our terms, who's everyone?
Earlier in the document and the preamble,
everyone's defined as all
members of the human family.
So this document is essentially declaring
if you're a member of the human family,
you should automatically
be considered a person.
Now to understand why
the UN would say that,
I think we need to put that document into
context for and understand the history
of how it came to be.
The Universal Declaration of Human
Rights was adopted in the late 1940s of
course we know when the early 1940s we
had the Holocaust where what happened?
Some humans were deprived of personhood
status based on some feature about them,
ethnicity, religion, sexual orientation,
and so the UN comes up with
this document to say no.
The one thing we all have in common is
our human nature and to ensure that we
don't repeat the injustices of the past.
It codifies,
it puts in writing this idea that if
you're a member of the human family,
you ought to automatically be considered
a person and you should not be deprived
of your personhood rights based
on some quality like ethnicity,
religion, sexual orientation, and
in the same way, if that's true,
then we ought to say the same thing about
what we know to be a human embryo in a
human fetus.
The quality of age shouldn't be the
basis for which someone has personhood
status and therefore they ought to be
considered persons according to article
six,
by virtue of being human,
not by virtue of being a certain age that
enables them as a result of their age
to be rational,
conscious and self aware in that moment
their is what is consistent as their age
and therefore abilities change.
If you think about the question,
when do we become persons?
I think what's helpful is to look
at the timeline from the moment of
fertilization to the moment of birth.
And if we draw the line
anywhere after fertilization,
we're ultimately basing it based on a
developmental stage or based on an age
which would fly in the face of human
rights doctrines which aren't to uh,
acknowledge human rights
based on abilities or aid.
But instead of knowledge,
human rights based on being human. And
we know at the moment of fertilization,
but oneself embryo has all the genetic
material distinguishing her from the
mother and the father.
And from that point forward,
you're going to change your appearance.
You're going to change your abilities,
you're going to change your age,
but you're human identity distinguishing
you from everyone else is going to be
what remains the same as I have dialogue
with a lot of people over the years.
Not only have I found the question of
personhood being raised in conversation,
but I have also found the question of the
dependency of the pre born child being
used as grounds to justify abortion.
Where some people will say, look,
if if someone has an infant
and they don't want the infant,
any of us in the room are
capable of caring for the infant,
but if someone doesn't want their fetus,
none of us in the room are
capable of caring for the fetus.
Therefore a woman should have
a right to have an abortion.
When I hear that argument,
what crosses my mind is does the greater
dependency of the fetus make the mother
less responsible or more responsible?
Well,
I found myself in conversation a few years
ago with a different student and this
young woman said to me,
look,
if you have a baby in one hand and a fetus
and the other hand you obviously pick
the baby.
And I thought to myself for a
moment about babies versus fetuses.
As it just said a moment ago, you know,
if there was a baby in this room napping,
we could all leave and come
back and the baby would be fine.
But if there was a fetus left out on the
podium here and we all leave and come
back, the fetus is going to be
dead. So I thought in a sense,
babies are stronger and fetuses are
weaker in relation to each other.
So I thought what,
what the student actually said to me,
although she didn't verbalize it,
was this,
if you have a strong person in one hand
and you have a weaker or person in the
other hand,
you obviously pick the stronger person.
And when I kind of translated in
my mind what she'd said to that,
I thought to myself, you don't, civil
societies actually do just the opposite.
We tend to prioritize weaker people
rather than stronger people. Again,
the captain prioritizes the
passengers are ought to and so forth.
And so I thought to myself,
how do I communicate that I think civil
societies actually would prioritize
weaker people ahead of stronger
people and as it should happen,
a story came to my mind.
And again, as I said,
I love telling stories is the story that
came to my mind, uh, relates to this.
And so I said to the student, what you
just said about babies versus fetuses.
Reminds me of a picture of my friend
posted on Facebook and I said it was a
picture of a river and in the middle of
the river was something slightly curvy
sticking up.
And in reality it was the kind of picture
that I would keep swiping away if it
hadn't been for the caption.
And the caption my friend posted
with this picture was this,
my husband is a hero.
And then my friend went on to explain
why as I then explained to the student.
My friend wrote,
my husband is a paramedic and is it at
midnight he was called to the scene of a
car accident.
A woman had been driving down the road.
She lost control of her vehicle
and is it spun out of control.
It landed in a nearby river.
When my friend's husband got to the scene,
he saw that that woman driver was
sitting on the roof of her sinking car,
holding her 10 month old baby in her arms.
My friend's husband jumps in the water,
swims towards the car and then realizes
he can only take one person at a time to
shore. I looked at the
student I was dialoguing with
and I asked her a question,
who do you think he picked first?
Obviously she knew the answer.
Will the baby correct? I said, why?
If you had to explain the reasoning why
he picked the baby over the mob to take
first, what would it be? She
said, well obviously, cause
if he picked the mom first,
then by the time he got back to the car,
the baby could have rolled in the
water and drowned. Correct. I said,
so would you say it's fair to summarize
your response to this story by
acknowledging that you believe when
you have a strong person in one hand,
like the mom and a weaker person
in the other hand, like the baby,
that we ought to prioritize the needs
of weaker people? She said, of course.
And then I brought it back to her original
point about babies versus fetuses.
And I said anyone could care for a baby
and a baby could be left alone for a
while, but only one person can care
for a fetus and cannot be left alone.
So in a sense the baby is stronger
like the mom in the story,
whereas the fetus is weaker like
the infant in the mom's arms.
And since you believe that we should
prioritize weaker and more vulnerable
people ahead of stronger people than
shouldn't we actually prioritize the needs
of the preborn trialed.
That point was something that was
emphasized very clearly in a different
encounter that I had through
what someone shared with me.
I was once at an exhibit that was
looking at parallels between historical
injustices and present Dan justices.
One of the parallels being the
Rwandan genocide and abortion,
the argument being that at the
time the Tutsis were slaughtered,
they weren't deemed to be equal to the
WHO to extremists but rather inferior and
because they were deemed to be inferior,
the dehumanizing actions were justified.
The parallel then being that someone
generally who supports abortion does not
say I think embryos and fetuses are equal
to us and I want to kill not at all,
but instead deem the embryo and fetus to
be inferior and therefore rationalizes
actions which would take away that
human's rights because they don't consider
them equal the argument than being
if we were wrong in the past about
dehumanizing one group of humans,
could we be wrong in the present about
dehumanizing and other group of humans.
So one of the signs that this exhibit
that I was standing with was this one and
a woman came past and stopped and began
to speak with me and she told me that
she was from Rwanda and she told me that
most of her family had been killed in
the genocide from the mid nineties and I
will admit I became very self conscious
standing representing this sign because
I began to wonder if perhaps this woman
would be offended by the
comparison that I was making,
but instead of assuming and wondering,
I thought the best thing I can do is seek
to understand and ask her a question.
And so I looked at this woman and I said,
given all you have told me about
the brutality that your family were,
your family members were victims of what
you just barely escaped by fleeing the
country before things got really bad.
How do you feel?
I said about this comparison I'm making.
And she stepped back and she
moved her gaze really for me,
she hadn't really looked that closely at
the picture and then she just stood in
silence for about 20 seconds.
Is she looked at this poster
and then finally she pointed to the
picture of the abort a child and she said,
that's worse
because at least my family
could try to run away.
This woman recognized the
greater, uh, humans vulnerability,
the greater another's
responsibility to wards that well.
So if we think about that,
that first quality that I have identified,
that inspiring people seem to have,
that people I've dialogued
with have shared with me.
It is the idea that we ought to put
others ahead of ourselves even when we
failed.
We know deep down that that's something
to aspire towards and it's clear that
the human embryo and fetus are an other,
just like the passengers in the airplane.
The next point that I wanted to
address today is the second quality.
I have found an inspiring people,
which is that they have perspective.
One of my favorite authors is Doctor
Victor Frankl who has written the book
man's search for meaning.
I love books and I love gifting
books to other people. And Man,
search for meaning is probably one the
leading book that I have given to a lot
of people. The other one would be
essential ism. Bye Bye Greg Kanaan,
which is a phenomenal book, but not
what I'm here to talk about right now.
But man, search for meaning I've
given away to so many people.
And this book was written by a man
who was a holocaust survivor and a
psychiatrist. And so man, search for
meaning is really a two part book.
The first part is about his
experiences in the concentration camps.
And the second part of his book
is his theories in psychology.
And one of the points that he
makes in his book is the following.
He said that he observed
both as a prisoner and as a
psychiatrist who in a sense
as a prisoner, was studying human
behavior as he was being victimized in,
in the concentration camps.
One of the things he observed is that
he would have expected all of the guards
to be cruel and most of them were.
But he said every now and then,
surprisingly amidst all the cruel guards,
there was someone who was kind and
then he said amongst the prisoners,
there were some who when treated like
animals became like animals and were cruel
to their fellow prisoners.
But there were others,
he said regardless of how
brutally they were treated,
maintained their humanity and
in they're starving state would,
would save morsels of food, not for
themselves, but for a fellow prisoner.
And when Doctor Frankel
makes this observation, it
draws him to this conclusion.
Someone can have a similar experience
but still choose a different response to
the experience.
And he says,
the last of the human freedoms that can
never be taken from us is the freedom to
choose how to respond to
the situation that we're in.
That is what perspective is inspired.
People who have perspective can be in a
horrible circumstance in a sense beyond
their control.
But the recognize what is still within
their control is their response to that
circumstance is their attitude.
And Doctor Frankl has come up with a
mathematical equation that explains the
power of perspective because in the
concentration camps he saw a lot of
suffering,
suffering that was so bad that some people
sought to commit suicide because they
despaired.
And Doctor Frankel said early on in his,
in his time at the concentration camps,
he decided he would never kill himself.
Moreover would he not commit suicide.
But he was going to try to dissuade
his fellow prisoners from doing that.
And he discovered the way to try to
convince them not to despair was to help
them find meaning.
And so his mathematical equation was
this d equals s minus m despair is
suffering without meaning.
He recognized in the present circumstances
removing the suffering was near
impossible,
but he could decrease despair to the
extent that he increased meaning and Dr.
Franco years after coming out of the
concentration camps sites and example,
where where this equation in a sense was
brought to life with a young teenager,
he learned about in Texas who
had become a quadriplegic.
Lot of times when people are asked,
you know,
imagine if you were suddenly paralyzed,
would you want to keep living?
And when we're not in that state,
we think, no I wouldn't. Well,
Dr. Franco sites and example of someone
who found herself not being asked that
question in a hypothetical, but that
was reality. She became quadriplegic.
She would spend her days watching
the news, reading the news,
and whenever she came across a story
of someone who is going through a very
difficult time of someone who
was suffering in some way,
she would ask an assistant to bring
a stick and place it in her mouth.
She would then use that stick bend over
to press keys on a keyboard so she could
write letters of encouragement to the
people she'd read about in the news.
And Doctor Frankel said,
her life is filled with an
abundant sense of meaning.
We decreased despair in the presence
of suffering to the extent we increase
meaning.
That's what I mean by perspective.
I saw the power of perspective up close
and personally a few years ago when I
had the privilege of spending an afternoon
with this young man, Nick Wojciech,
how many of you have heard
of this motivational speaker?
I did a quick Google search as to whether,
um,
you had a toxic Google with nick for
Trish and I don't think you have.
So I highly recommended
this guy's hilarious. So it
helps that he has an accent.
He's from Australia. I just think
accents are cool and uh, uh,
but he's really funny.
So anyways,
I know someone who knows
someone who knows nick and um,
he was coming to the city. I used
to live in, in Canada, in Calgary.
And so I thought I got to try and meet
this guy because I talk about his story
so often.
So sure enough,
he was a willing to meet with me and
my colleagues and we surprised my
colleagues with him.
They didn't know that he was
coming and they all knew his story.
So when he came to the office,
they were shocked like there
was no way this isn't you.
And then nick looks at everyone,
he goes, I'm not nik void church.
I'm his stunt double.
So anyways,
nick is a funny guy. He lives a full
life. He loves traveling the world,
speaking to millions of
people and inspiring them,
getting access to audiences I could
only dream of Getty access to.
And it's because of what he doesn't have.
It's because of his lack of limps.
He at this disability as an opportunity,
but he didn't always have that attitude.
He didn't always have that perspective.
When Nick was a child,
he was bullied and taunted and made fun
of so much that one night while lying in
the family bathtub,
he thought about rolling over and drowning
himself in an act of suicide. Now.
He obviously didn't do that,
but what's also obvious is that
his circumstances didn't change.
He still lacks the LIMS now
that he lacked in that bathtub.
So what's changed his perspective?
Instead of thinking about what his
lack of limbs prevents him from doing,
he started to think about what his
lack of limbs and enabled him to do.
The afternoon I spent with him,
I spent also with another family.
He had invited along and that family
included this two year old girl Brooke,
and as you can see,
Brooke doesn't have arms.
Nick's lack of limbs was not
diagnosed in Utero by ultrasound.
It was only discovered when he was born.
Brooks lack of limbs,
her lack of arms on the other hand was
discovered while her mom was pregnant via
ultrasound and when the mom went for a
routine ultrasound and they saw the fetus
didn't have arms,
the doctors offered to do an abortion.
Brooke's parents said no,
they didn't have a smartphone at the time.
So they went home. And where
do you think they went? Kugel.
I've told this story so much, but I have
to say I've never told it at Google.
So I think that's really cool.
So uh,
they went onto Google and they typed no
arms enter and the first hit was Neva
Boyd change and they spent the rest
of that pregnancy looking at videos of
someone who was like their daughter.
And then an opportunity came two years
after she was born for them to drive
eight hours through the mountains from
British Columbia to Alberta in western
Canada to see in the flash someone
who looked like their daughter.
And when I saw nick and Brooke Interact,
I thought he is uniquely positioned to
motivate and Inspire Brooke in a way her
parents can't, in a way her sister
can't, in a way, none of us could.
And it's because of what he doesn't have.
His obstacle is now his opportunity.
That's the power of perspective.
I think that can be then obviously
related to the abortion discussion.
How can we change our perspective
in an unplanned crisis situation?
In another occasion where
I was on a college campus,
a student came to the microphone and said,
my stepmom had an abortion because she
was told her fetus was going to die at
birth.
Are you telling me she was wrong?
And I first expressed sympathy to the
students saying that I was sorry for the
suffering that his stepmom went through
and I don't pretend to know what that
must've been like and I said to him,
you're a question is a fair one and
I'm going to answer it, but I said,
if you'll bear with me,
I believe I can best address your
question by engaging you in a dialogue by
asking you some questions. Would
that be okay? He said, sure.
I said,
okay,
well the question I have for you actually
involve setting aside the abortion
topic for just a moment and entering
into a thought experiment. I said,
I want you to imagine that someone you
love dearly on the opposite end of the
country calls you,
calls you today and says,
I've just been diagnosed with cancer and
I've been given four weeks left to live.
I looked at this student and I said,
would you wait until week three,
day six to hop on a plane and go say
goodbye to the person you love or I said,
would you take the next flight out and
savor every moment of every day of the
next four weeks with the person you love?
And he said, well, the second option.
I said, me too, and here's what
I think this says about us.
What do you think it says about us is we
recognize when we have a minimal amount
of time left with someone we love,
we want to maximize the minimal time.
We don't want to cut short the already
short time we have that's perspective.
So I said,
let's take that principle,
that perspective and let's apply it to
the situation your stepmom found herself
in before that poor prenatal diagnosis.
She probably thought she had 50 years
with her child and in one moment of
hearing that news,
your baby's going to die at birth.
She went from having 50 years
to roughly 20 weeks. I said,
based on your analysis of
the thought experiment,
why would we cut short the already
short time we have left instead?
Wouldn't we want to savor every moment
of every day of the next 20 weeks with a
child that we love now upon the
birth happening in the trial dying?
Would there be sorrow, grief? Absolutely.
But if you have the abortion
and you want it to be pregnant
with there be sorrow and grief.
Yes.
So having the abortion instead of
carrying on 20 more weeks is not going to
spare sadness,
but it will rob you of the gift of time.
And that's again where we
want the power of perspective.
The final point that I wanted to address
this morning was that quality of,
of inspiring people,
which is to do the right
thing even when it's hard.
If you think about it,
that fits with your code of conduct.
I know you have a slogan here of don't
be evil. And when alphabet came to be,
it came and got a little broader,
uh, to do the right thing.
But we know that we should do the
right thing even when it's hard.
And I think that's relevant
in the abortion discussion.
If we think for a moment
about the circumstances that
a pregnant woman could be
in,
and if we think about the reasons that
were prompt someone to have an abortion,
we can acknowledge this is hard.
Magine being pregnant from
a rape and being in poverty,
having health problems,
uh,
just not wanting the child
or being really young,
having no support in each
of these situations. What,
wherever someone sits on the abortion
debate, what side of the fence they're on,
there's agreement to be pregnant and port
be hard to be pregnant and young would
be hard to be pregnant from rape
would be excrutiatingly difficult.
There's no denying the difficulty
in these circumstances.
The question is what ought we
do when circumstances are hard?
Well, let's imagine the circumstances are
these, but not with a pregnant person,
but someone who's
parenting this born child.
Would it be easy or hard to take
care of this child and poverty hard?
It would be easy or hard to to
care for this child and be 14 hard.
Would it be easy or hard to parent this
child knowing every day you look in her
face, you're reminded her father
was a rapist. It would be hard.
Would we ever allow someone to end this
child's life because the circumstances
for the parent
or heart
wouldn't.
We would say we need to do the
right thing even when it's hard.
And so I would suggest in the
various encounters I've had that we,
that we have the same attitude
when it comes to this life.
Since we know this is a living human
being who according to article six of the
UN ought to be considered a person who's
simply younger than the rest of us.
And since human rights aren't grounded
in age, they're grounded and being human,
then we ought to say,
here is we say there we have to do
the right thing even when it's hard.
And that brings to mind several people
I've had the privilege of meeting who I
believe by their stories have inspired
me to do the right thing when it's hard
in my own life,
the way they've done that.
And there's a few months ago I spoke in
Guatemala and I spoke alongside another
speaker.
Uh,
my friend here Lyanna Lyanna and I
met for the first time in Guatemala.
She speaks both spink Spanglish,
she speaks English and Spanish.
I on the other hand,
only speak English.
And so I had a translator
translate for the audience by talk,
but because she's spoken Spanish,
that meant when she gave her
talk I couldn't understand it.
So it wasn't until we got
to the restaurant after
giving our first presentation
in, uh, in, in the hotel,
we were staying in that evening that we
shared our stories and got to know each
other. And as we were talking,
she mentioned that she
was 37 and I said, no way,
I'm 36. And then a short while later
she mentioned that she had a daughter.
And I said, well, how old is
your daughter? And she said 25
and then I did the math and I thought 25
years ago I was 11 which means 25 years
ago,
Leanna was 12 and Leanna told me her
story that growing up in Mexico City when
she was 12 one day,
two men kidnapped her,
held her for two days
and brutally raped her.
She got pregnant from that rape and when
she went to the doctor and discovered
this,
the doctors offered her an abortion and
Leanna asked the doctors if abortion
would help her forget the rape if it
would help ease her pain and suffering.
And the doctor said,
well no it won't do that.
And she realized in that moment that if
ending her baby's life wouldn't benefit
anybody,
she wasn't going to do it.
And Leanna said if abortion
wasn't going to heal anything,
I didn't see the point. She said, I
just knew I had somebody inside my body.
I never thought about who her
biological father wise, she was my kid,
she was inside of me and just knowing she
needed me made me want to get a job to
help her.
But in an interview Leanna did.
She shared that although that was
her attitude about the pregnancy,
the rape itself caused her
life to become a living hell.
No matter how many times she showered,
she could not get rid of the
feeling that she was dirty.
And so she started to entertain
thoughts or she thought about committing
suicide. But when she thought
about committing suicide,
she remembered she was pregnant and she
had to think not only about herself but
about the child.
And so she didn't kill herself.
And she looked at me in that restaurant
in Guatemala and she said to me,
Stephanie,
I saved my daughter's life,
but she saved mine.
In another story of an inspiring person
I've met who I believe brings this third
principle to life,
I'm reminded of a young woman by the name
of Veronica who was a college student
who got pregnant unexpectedly.
And um,
her boyfriend wanted her
to have an abortion and her
friends wanted her to have
an abortion,
but she ended up telling her parents and
moving back home and getting support.
And she sent me this picture of
her and her daughter, Emilia.
And I'd like to read for you what she
said to me when she sent this picture.
She said, the picture I've enclosed of
Amelia, and I doesn't fully show my face,
but it's an important picture to me.
Emilia became very ill with respiratory
problems around seven months,
which meant a lot of nights
dealing with fever, congestion,
pain control,
and a sad little baby who kept waking up
due to having trouble breathing in her
sleep.
She said,
I took this picture one night when I
decided to let her sleep on my chest
instead of the crib and she
slept throughout the night.
And so I did that every night until
she was better. And she said to me,
it represents what we do as mothers,
that we stop looking at ourselves
as individuals with needs.
And instead we begin to look at how we
can serve another and therefore love
another.
And with doing that she said
comes learning to love ourselves.
And finally I'm reminded
of my friend Debbie.
Debbie's story is similar to Leanna's
in Veronica Veronica's in that she was
unexpectedly pregnant,
but unlike Leanna's and Veronica's story,
Debbie had an abortion.
And she deeply regrets having made that
choice but realizes like all of us,
she cannot undo her past.
But you came convicted that if she had
regrets and she knew the impact of her
choice back then,
that she lives with now,
that she would have wanted
someone to tell their story.
And so she's decided to tell her story
to try to help people think differently
when it comes to the crisis they're in.
And so she travels to different audiences
and she talks about her choice and she
talks about regretting it.
And once she was in an audience where
a student had a friend on route to an
abortion clinic and he's
simply sent his friend a text,
there's a woman here who regrets her
abortion. And the friend texted back why?
And so this young woman was willing to
sit down with Debbie and listen to not
only Debbie story,
but give Debbie and opportunity to listen
to her and what her reasonings were
for abortion.
And she felt she had no support,
that she couldn't get through that
pregnancy and parenting. So Debbie said,
all support. You and your
friend here, we'll support you.
That girl didn't go to the
abortion clinic that day,
but she did go the next day to hear her
child's heartbeat and then she decided
to carry through with that pregnancy and
several months later this baby girl was
born and to wrap everything up
before we move it into questions,
they just want to leave you with the
thought that whether it's this teenage mom
who not only is delighted
that she has this baby,
but she encouraged another friend to
carry through with the pregnancy that that
friend is grateful to have.
Whether it's this teenage mom or whether
it's Debbie or whether it's Lee Hannah
or Veronica,
whether it's little brook or her parents,
whether it's a captain Sullenberger
who prioritized the passengers on his
airplane, whether it's Nick
Vori church that you remember.
All these people in think,
you know they're inspiring because they
put others ahead of themselves because
they had perspective and because they
did the right thing even when it was
really hard. And that's the challenge
that I leave all of you with today.
Thank you very much.
At this point I would be happy
to engage you in a dialogue,
a conversation and a
question and answer periods.
So if you have questions about the topic
in general or anything I've shared,
I would be happy to answer them in.
Mark has a microphone over there
and in tea we'll take it around.
So
any questions?
I was wondering how do you suggest
creating a dialogue like this in an
environment which is almost entirely
for abortion? So how do you,
how do you even start this conversation
when you know there was such a strong
outward resistance to a
pro life point of view?
You don't,
hopefully it came through in the stories
that I shared that I think a lot of the
times the way we start conversations,
whether we think it's an environment
that's going to be friendly or not so
friendly is to start conversations
with open ended questions.
So I will ask people,
what do you think about abortion?
And if that might seem
like a really random,
not so much lunch table conversation,
you could maybe find an article in the
newspaper or something that you read
about online that somehow
relates and bring it up and see,
did you see that article about
x, Y, or z? And it made me think,
what do you think about this topic?
What do you think about abortion?
And really seek to understand where that,
where that person is coming from.
And to give you an example,
once on an airplane, um, a
guy sitting next to me, we,
we shared what our jobs were and
he asked what I did and I said, I,
I go and give talks about abortion. And
he said, really? That's fascinating.
And I just looked at him and said, what
do you think about abortion? And he said,
I think it's necessary sometimes. And
I just asked another question. I said,
when do you think it's necessary? And he
said, like, cases of rape. And I said,
you know,
I agree with you that rape is a horrible
evil and we need to not only support
the woman who's been victimized,
but we need far more serious consequences
for the rapist. And then I said to him,
I have to ask myself a question though,
and the question I have to ask myself,
is this,
is it fair to give the death
penalty to the innocent child?
And his passenger looked
at me and he said, well, I
never thought of it that way.
And so I didn't go in boarding my
plane with the intention to, you know,
speak about abortion.
I just asked a few questions when
someone asks me what my job was.
Any other questions?
All right.
So I have a friend who says he's pro life.
Like if you were with a woman who's
pregnant here at rarely dare everything in
his power to persuade her to choose life.
But he says he wouldn't want to impose
that decision. So what else? What is your,
so that's,
that's a common perspective people have
is I feel this way and I might even
encourage you,
but I can't force my views on human so
far is I don't think the law, for example,
should reflect how I would live.
And when someone says that,
I think analogies are helpful, I
would, I would ask a question and, and,
and draw an analogy out
of it. I would say, well,
would you say that you're
against rape? Yes. Uh,
and if someone was going to commit rape,
would you try to stop them?
Yes.
And do you think if you're incapable of
stopping them and they actually commit
rape,
that we ought to have laws that ban rate.
So there are consequences for that person.
And if they say yes, then I would say,
okay,
so you clearly think under some
circumstances we should have laws that say
certain actions are wrong.
So then why when it comes to abortion,
would you treat it differently if
abortion ends the life of a human being?
Now if abortion doesn't end
the life of a human being,
then I think we can call into question.
Should we have any laws against it.
But since we know we're dealing
with a human being that's living,
then if the act of abortion
ends that human being's life,
it's not enough for me to say,
I personally won't kill someone.
But if you want to kill someone, that's
you're right. If the facts are true,
if the evidence is there, we have to
go to its logical conclusion and say,
if this action end someone's
life, it's wrong. Not just for me,
but it's wrong for everyone.
And we ought to have laws against it
as we do with rape and other types of
murder and and other things like that.
So we can't determine whether we should
quote unquote force our views on other
people until we know what the
view is. Like, for example,
a lot of times people say,
I support a woman's right to choose.
We have to finish our sentence. That's
not grammatically correct. Choose what?
It's hanging there.
I support a woman's right to choose what
color shoes to wear with her outfit.
Sure. What kind of ice cream
she thinks is the best. Sure.
But I don't support a woman's right
to choose to kill an innocent child
regardless of the child's age. So
in a similar way, if I said to you,
I support a man's right to take, you would
have to ask me to define what I mean.
Take what and if it's a support of man's
right to take his bag and walk out of
the room,
totally okay.
But I don't support a man's right to
take someone else's bag out of the room.
So we need to define what we mean by
choice, by take by, by all of this stuff.
And if in defining it evidence leads us
to the fact that we're actually ending
someone's life or violating
a human right then,
then we have to create a structure legally
that bands that for the interests of
our fellow human beings.
Any other questions?
I haven't really quite formulated my
question on top of using that same analogy
then. Um, what could kind of,
what incarcerating a mother be when,
when we're talking about the issue,
the issue being that woman do not
have enough support right now. Um,
so what would, what good would, um,
making it illegal do for the woman and,
and showing her that there is support
for her? That there is like another way?
Very good question. So certainly I
would say it's not just one strategy.
Add the uh, you know, and I know
abandoning all other strategies, the,
the slogan I like to use is
make abortion unthinkable,
but in believing it ought
to be unthinkable based
on the evidence of dealing
with a human being and
believing in human rights, um,
believing it ought to be unthinkable
doesn't exclude me from saying I also
believe it ought to be. I do believe it
ought to be illegal and unthinkable. Um,
what would be the consequences for
woman who violates the law? Well,
the first point is no woman is
currently violating the law.
So we're not talking about,
for example,
putting women in jail
who had had abortions.
What we're talking
about is a hypothetical.
At some future point when the law changes,
what ought the consequences be?
And even when we say something is illegal,
you know,
it's illegal to steal what
the consequences are for
any individual who steals
vary from case to case.
You might find a situation where a woman
has an abortion under emotional duress.
She does not actually is not freely
choosing it. It's against the law.
But someone's pressuring her or forcing
her to go there against her will.
So that would be one example.
Or you have cases like Andrea Yates where
you have a woman who drowned her born
children in the bathtub and believe
in her case, she was not found,
she was found not criminally responsible.
Um,
her actions were still wrong
and they're still unlawful,
but a case was made or could be made in
circumstances like this where someone
was not have the right frame of mind to
be fully consenting to the action that
they were taking. So all of that
needs to be taken into account.
But the reality is the law
currently isn't against abortion.
And so what I think is very important
as efforts are made to have the law
changed to reflect human rights,
that all of us have the inalienable
right to life. In the meantime,
we have to offer support to
women. Absolutely. And there
are a pregnancy centers,
there are homes for pregnant women,
there are at nonprofits across the country
that exists to do that very thing and
to not only journey with a
woman through her pregnancy,
but to really walk with her
after her pregnancy as well.
If she chooses to parent
rather than adoption,
she's going to need a lot of
support in these centers exist.
And I would say very much should
have our attention and support.
So I hope that was helpful.
Any final questions?
Or you're given giving an inspiring talk.
So you're kind of like that good person
quality at your that you're kind of
mentioning.
So I was going to ask a personal question.
What inspires you to be who you
are to give talks around the world?
Oh, well thank you. I, in terms
of what inspires me, you know,
I'm just speaking of
pregnancy centers there.
My mom volunteered at a pregnancy
center when I was a young child.
Both my parents were really active in the
pro life cause you could say generally
speaking, but in particular my mom
volunteered at a pregnancy centers.
So when clients would come for pregnancy
tests I would often go with her and I
would do it on letterhead while she
was in the office counseling the girls.
And when those clients gave birth,
my mom would go to the hospital
with flowers and I would come along.
And so from a very young age I saw that
there were women in crisis who felt they
had no support.
And I saw that there were people like
my parents and my mom who would support
them and love them through that difficult
circumstance and turn that obstacle
they were in into opportunity.
And that laid the foundation to really
convict me to want to use the skills that
I had to help those who were
more vulnerable and in need.
And I went to university actually with
plans to pursue a different career.
But I heard an American speaker who came
to Canada and I was a college student.
His name is Scott clues,
and,
and he gave a presentation on
this topic that blew my mind.
And in that talk he said,
there are more people working
full time to kill babies.
Then there are working full time
to save them. And I'll admit,
when I heard those words,
I became very convicted that I want it
to be one of the people being a voice for
those who were entirely incapable of
raising their voices against what was
happening to them. And, and
a lot of things unfolded.
And here I am 15 years later.
Thank you very much.
That's great.
If you guys have any remaining
unasked questions, a,
she'll be here or you can talk
to her in person. And again,
we have copies of her book.
Love unleashes life.
So thank you very much for coming
and for those tuning in as well too.
Thank you.